لا أعرف ما الذي فعلوه
أثناء خموله ولكن هنا نعتني به على مدار
24 ساعة
ولدينا ميزات مذهلة
وأطباء دقيقون يقفون خلفه في كل تفاصيله،
لذلك
تحدثنا دائمًا في الأندية عن هذا الأمر.  من
الصعب بالنسبة لي أن
أفهم عندما تنفق الكثير من المال
مع اللاعبين وكيف تعيش معهم،
لا أعرف ما هي الأندية الأخرى، هل
تفضل تجربتي في الماضي،
لذا اليوم المنظمة مع هذا
الجدول الزمني المتطلب  كل ثلاثة أو أربعة أيام
خلف اللاعبين، يجب أن تكون
حاشية مذهلة للعناية
بهم، الأمر يتطلب الكثير اليوم ومن حيث
التغذية والباقي النوم والطعام
والتدريب وكم عدد
الدقائق التي تعلم أن هناك
أيامًا لا يستطيعون فيها ذلك.  تدرب
أكثر من 10 15 دقيقة وإلا
ستكون مخاطرة كما تعلم والناس يقولون
لماذا نستبدل
ضد أه أحمر الشفاه عند تسجيل
الأهداف أو كيف البديل ضد
الفريق اللاتيني بعد يوم واحد من
الإصابة بعد مباراة بيرلي كانت 10  أيام 15
يومًا لم يتمكن من اللعب مع النرويج
لا يمكنه اللعب معنا ضد ليفربول
لأننا نعلم حينها أن ذلك يجب أن يكون مثل
الساعة كما تعلمون لأنها كبيرة جدًا
ويجب أن يتم
تدليكها بشكل شرس وظهره وأكتافه
ومشكلته في أوتاره و و
كل شيء لذلك عليك أن تكون كما لو أنه
يعمل الكثير من الوقت ولكن الكثير من
الوقت
داخل القطار الموجود على الشاطئ